alright guys listen up say what you want
about our friend mr. dear but when a
flamboyant time-stopping vampire with an
invisible friend tells you to subscribe
to the new order view a regular judge
our content uploaded straight into your
YouTube feed then I personally think
that you should just probably acquiesce
and do it hello and welcome to the new
order video source for everything anime
manga and today we are here to tackle
the topic of a man who is much larger
than life itself the notorious and
legendary deal of JoJo's Bizarre
Adventure now at this stage it is pretty
undeniable that do is what I would call
a flag bearer of JoJo's Bizarre
Adventure more so than any of our actual
Georgia protagonists I mean for example
when I was an outsider looking in on the
madness that was Georgia I could not
name a single protagonist all I really
knew is that there was some cool-looking
dude with a hat you know whose name I
did know do they had never watched or
read Georgia but this character had
already somehow carved out some space
for himself in my life as if he had
transcended the very pages he was drawn
on and to quite a large degree I do
believe that is true do is a very rare
existence in fiction who has been
elevated to a position far beyond
anything his actions in Georgia could
possibly live up to and for an awfully
long time as I was diligent ly working
my way through the series I asked myself
on several occasions what is so
appealing about deer because I am in on
all of this now so I should get it right
and for an awfully long time I just
didn't it only really properly hit me
after I'd finished what was available of
part 8 and I looked back on the series
as a whole and realized in alright
that's the appeal of deer because the
very interesting thing for me is that
looking back at deers actions and varied
roles in the story none of them are
wildly impressive on their own but as a
whole they are held together by the very
simple and alluring factor of
personality that is quite literally the
only thing that I believe deer has going
for him in JoJo's Bizarre Adventure but
as it turns out that would be more than
enough
but even then that took time it took me
specifically quite a lot of time
actually so stepping into the genesis of
giorgo as I often do phantom blood does
need to come up in conversation here
because after having this presence that
is deer imprinted on my life through
various bombardments of meme culture I
was expecting big big things from him
here and he just did not deliver do is a
guy who I found to be a bit of a dick
for the sake of being a bit of a dick
and they do accept that there was a lot
more to that which has made very clear
in our keys book entitled manga in
theory and practice
and in regards to part one do he says
the following
India's case I depicted him as coming
from an unfortunate upbringing saddled
with a father who had no redeeming
qualities whatsoever it gave him a
background that could explain his hunger
for power and his willingness to become
evil incarnate to obtain it and the
ideas are definitely there I can't argue
that I just don't personally feel that
that intention was quite as effective as
I he may have intended so for example
there are certain aspects of Part one
dear that yeah I can get on board with
like poisoning both Daario and George
because those were evil acts committed
for the sake of raw ambition and it does
further his status but then there's also
a massive aspect of deer being cruel for
the sake of being cruel like the really
vicious way in which he killed Danny and
the moment in which he rejects humanity
by embracing the story mask is very much
the point of no return for me in part
one from then onwards do is
indistinguishable from a generic demon
albeit much more flamboyant I found it
very difficult to connect with him and I
guess that's because of his pure
rejection of humanity and as a result I
couldn't form that empathetic link with
him that I managed to achieve with
almost every other major antagonist from
powerful onwards because they all have
very strongly human identifying features
Medea rejected all of that and as such
he became a very flat villainous
existence something that to be fair I
would like to realize would work to his
advantage but for now I wanted more a
lot more and part one did not give it to
me so let's now cut to part three where
I discover that do is once again going
to play the role of main antagonist and
this has me initially quite excited
because I thought to myself well part
one was just an aberration and this must
be where the true love video comes from
and so I waited patiently for like 45
episodes for him to eventually take the
stage and while he was significantly
more of a presence and in phantom blood
and yes the world is fantastic
dear didn't actually offer anything new
to me he still felt really flat in terms
of almost everything and it was as if
there was nothing more to his existence
and simply being a pain in the
collective asses of every Joestar family
member and this is where he meets his
end so I was left quite initially
unsatisfied by dear especially in
comparison to a character like your
chicag Akira who would immediately
follow him up in part 4 and therefore
always draws my direct comparison the
key represented an incredible degree of
depth and subtlety he was the exact
opposite kind of antagonist to deer and
that's the sort of thing that I
generally personally prefer but it would
eventually lead me to reassessing deer's
role in the series because I don't think
I have stopped to appreciate what here
was in my relentless quest for just
wanting more of him and what do is is a
cartoon villain he does not exist to
explore the dark ideas of humanity or to
present himself as sympathetic or an
empathetic presence do is designed with
a very clear technical narrative purpose
to serve as a thing to be defeated and
to be as entertaining as possible whilst
doing it and so it's a bit bizarre
because on paper there should be nothing
redeeming about deer in terms of
personality doesn't really present
anything we can identify with
he's an almost purely demonic presence
removed from humanity itself and in
addition to that once go on paper there
should be nothing that redeems him from
a storytelling standpoint because apart
from the very early days of phantom
blood and acting as a thing to be
defeated in part 3do has no incredible
effect on the story and just to note
here this is my impression before we get
to part 6 but for the rest of part 1
deer just sits and waits for Jonathan
and then in part 3 he sits and waits for
Joe and Joseph and yet with these two
heavily detrimental features do is
somehow still so damn undeniably
charming and memorable this should not
be the case in theory he should quite
possibly be considered the worst villain
in the series although then again Kars
does exist so let's put that thought to
rest but deer shines entirely through
personality even if he is the polar
opposite of everything that humanity
holds up and disgust you with every
single action he commits there is
something disturbingly admirable about
him and I put a lot of that down to do
having an uncompromising personality as
humans we have very fragile creatures in
general and an awful lot of a second
guest pretty much every decision we are
faced with and as a result the people we
look up to aren't the ones that are able
to overcome that and see clearly or at
the very least exude a sense of
confidence in what they're doing so when
we're faced with a character like do
there is almost no choice but to admire
him to some degree because he no stage
comes to question himself do is
supremely confident in his actions and
combined with the various powers and
strength to gathers this results in the
sculpting of an individual who can very
much be seen as one who has transcended
the cesspool of humanity and iraki often
depicts him in this manner particularly
in part 3 where he is often drawn posing
like a statue of some sort of mythical
figure which does make him larger than
life itself and to counter the argument
I made about deer only having a handful
of episodes to actually do anything and
start us Crusaders with this context in
mind that was probably for the best more
time do spends on a page or on screen
the more that mythical Sheen would have
great because every moment he spends
with us can only serve to humanize this
figure more and in this case we don't
necessarily want that he needed to
maintain an aura of mystery and have our
imaginations do the heavy lifting in
regards to propping him up as the
ultimate enemy which is achieved very
well through the glimpses we get of him
in part three whereas if we did
experience a lot of deer then by the
time we did eventually get to facing off
against him he would not seem anywhere
near the almost godlike being that our
ki had cast him as now I'm not saying
that this was 100% intentional because
stardust crusaders has very frustrating
storytelling issues being a very basic
creation that waffels around for 90% of
its lifespan and then concludes however
really strangely enough I believe that
deer was used pretty damn perfectly
within this framework and I also think
that I see part 3 in a different light
due to having further contacts from
other parts to work with specifically
part 6 which looks back on deers
character and does offer a different
perspective on him to the one we were
given in parts 1 & 3 without going into
spoilers for Stone Ocean this is much
more what I was looking for were deer
and it succeeded in granting him the
depth I craved so much which of course
has given me a very favorable
retrospective opinion of mr. deer but
even with what we have in DEA's prime
period of relevance it's harder to
complain about what he is I mean yes
he's completely detestable in every way
but he's a villain and I guess that's
very much what a villain is designed to
do we can't all be Yoshi Carter heroes
Plus Diaz brand of evil is also quite
unique because if he was to be put into
the alignment system looking at the
ideas of you know lawful evil neutral
evil and chaotic evil he doesn't quite
fit any of them and I would offer that
we placed ear within his own category of
flamboyant evil a brand of sickening
evil that is applied with style and
flair thus making it somewhat enjoyable
to watch or read about actually to give
do a comparison to another series close
to my heart being hunter hunter I would
be tempted to put him in a similar
league to a figure like Hisoka who is
100% a selfish detestable existence but
the way he conducts himself with a sense
of style is nothing short of completely
compelling although and he soaked his
case he has arguably many more
humanizing figures and gray area moments
in Deerwood so deer represents more of
an absolute and he's almost like a bit
of a cult leader actually watching or
reading deer you know for a fact that
this guy is not someone that you want to
be involved with but you can't help but
go further down that rabbit hole with
every word he says and then before you
know it you've been inducted into the
cult of Zorah door and you're announced
your entire life crofting dear related
memes and speaking of memes I would be
remiss not to mention that those play a
role in catapulting do into the
stratosphere of popularity because in
this day and age memes more or less have
the ability to make or break a series
and I actually tribute memes to being a
key factor in George's late stage
success as well as a barrier to entry
mind you because they can get slightly
out of control and do is at the center
of most of that behavior so even though
it was almost entirely unintentional our
key has creative character who was very
easily adopted into this modern
globalized society in the words kono da
da da da da and Roger Ola are somewhat
ingrained into the psyche of people who
are not even fans of Georgia are
actually people who aren't even fans of
anime and manga in general and that
dominant mean presence of dear also very
much affects how he is viewed in the
actual series because these memes which
are very much created to generate humor
only endear us more to this demonic
psychopath so people who have
experienced a lot of this come into
Georgia with an immediate bias towards
liking him because we've seen him used
with humorous situations on the Internet
and for better or worse I think that
deer has become just as much with meme
culture as he was with Jonathan's body
but to end on some actual substance of
the series deal is probably made most
prominent by his legacy on every other
Georgia part
he is quite a powerful presence and
arguably the reason why anything in
Georgia happens at all which is pretty
obviously seen in a character like Jonah
who was part deer pot Jonathan or even
more subtly in part for and with his
legacy even driving the core action of
part 6 and then when Eric he decided to
start his own alternate Church of us do
had to leave his mark there as well in
the form of Diego Brando it was a pretty
fantastic incarnation of deer although
definitely not quite as cartoonishly
flamboyantly evil as his namesake which
personally I loved quite a lot and I
think that Diego is the ultimate form of
deer but all of this is what makes deer
such an incredible figure talk back on
because even if I wasn't satisfied by
what he presented during his tenure of
being alive looking back on everything
that was and is dear it becomes
impossible to deny what an absurdly
powerful character he is who with every
narrative feature going against him
managed to pierce the heavens and become
the undeniable face of JoJo's Bizarre
Adventure but what do you guys think
please do let me know in the comments
below or if you're keen for some
moderator content then please do go and
check out some of my other videos I'll
even subscribe to the channel for
regular Georgia Wanda delivered straight
until YouTube feed but for now this has
been the New World
you and I'll see you next time